[Music]
you don't have to be nervous i'm not
nervous
well
so impressive you're impressive they're
going to be obsessed with you
[Music]
they're not as nihilistic as they look
on the internet you guys this is me oh
whoa
this is your first relationship oh no
you just kind of give that vibe
oh you know that has weed in there right
[Music]
who wants to play body spotty spotties
so how do you play
if you draw the piece of paper that has
the x on it you are the murderer let's
go
and if you're the murderer you have to
kill someone by touching them on the
back
the most important part if you come
across a body you have to yell
[Music]
is that the lights
david
our friend is dead
[Music]
where are you
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm staying safe really because it looks
like you're grabbing a meat cleaver to
go look for my boyfriend
[Music]
i brought something what is it
it's zucchini bread
yum
girl pop girl rich girl i'm a girl false
girl catch me if you can go
[Music]
you